I think you guys both suck no I love
both of you and you know Marissa you I
think maybe a little richer than he is
so I'm just voting for like the shadiest
person of the house you were the sole
girl who voted for us yes
what went into that decision I think
that people were taking a little too
personally it is game he played the best
game Marissa you know kind of rode his
coattails she let him do all the dirty
work and then spoofed in and knew he was
gonna be the villain and it's like you
can say with me
my so you know I just I thought that he
played the best game
it's a shady game but that is the game
next up we have marriage boot camp night
what was that experience late and what
can we expect so I'm always true to
myself but and now I'm with my father
and if you can imagine I actually care
what he thinks and I care what you know
I'm still myself but I care about him so
much I love him to death and having
other people come at him or come with me
I was like nope you're also single again
you're back on the market
what are you looking for this time
around so I mean like I'm single not
with the ex-boyfriend no I have it well
you know you have a go-to okay so my go
shoot from before we had to like work
that out not last night Friday night
because my kids had to block Kenter so
yeah I got them back on Saturday so you
got out of that house and when it had
sex right I think you do what are you
looking for another relationship because
the last one has got pretty serious I'm
not looking for anything I really
honestly I love being single it's like
you don't have that pit in your stomach
if someone's doing something wrong or
cheating or doing something like that
it's like I just don't I can't go
through that ever again
what exactly happened that ended the
last one
I I'm going to play the pit all right
well you were just very vocal you said
the Instagram thoughts you can have him
yeah no I think social media it ruins
romances and you know it
it probably ruin mine but it he was
lovely and I am we're still really close
friends romantic fit long-term yeah yeah
but you said I'll take it
[Music]